over the decades of television and film
depictions of the riddler several
talented actors have played the
over-the-top villain but which version
of the riddler truly captures the
essence of the character keep watching
to see every live-action version of the
riddler ranked worst to best
better known for his portrayal of gomez
adams on the original adams family tv
series john aston also showed up on
another iconic 60s genre show in 1967 he
was cast as the riddler on the second
season of abc's classic adam west
starring batman series subbing in for
the role's original performer frank
gorshian
to this day there are different
explanations floating around as to why
gorshin was replaced either he was busy
with a gig he couldn't get out of or he
demanded a pay raise that producers
refused to give him whatever the truth
of the matter the result was the same
aston while a great actor was pointedly
a replacement and he felt like one but
i've only started with the cape
crusaders i'm going to confound them
with conundrums unnerve them with
enigmas perplexed them with puzzles
until they wish they were dead
although he did a fine job with the role
aston simply didn't have enough time to
really make the character his own under
the shadow of gorshin's work indeed by
the next season gorshin had already been
brought back as if nothing had happened
still aston did manage to give his
portrayal some memorable touches such as
a cane twirl that would later prove an
influence on jim carrey's tank
batman forever is not a lot of people's
favorite cinematic iteration of the
caped crusaders mythos but decades later
this take on batman through the lens of
nostalgia has aged nicely for some fans
and one of the many imperfect elements
that some fans have a soft spot for is
jim carrey's performance as the riddler
heavily influenced by frank gorshian's
classic turn this was the first
live-action version of the character to
get a proper backstory and the first to
be referred to by his common name edward
nigma on paper it seemed like the
perfect role for carrie with a descent
into madness arc that could play to his
strengths as both a comedic and dramatic
performer but the broad ham-fisted
writing didn't tamp fully into the
things that made the riddler complex and
interesting as a villain elements like
his hubris his deep insecurity masked by
grandstanding and his tremendous
intelligence were generally left by the
wayside who are you
just a friend
but you can call me
the riddler
kerry was therefore stranded on an
island of goofiness left to carry the
character with just his sheer madcap
energy and commitment the performance is
highly charismatic and memorable it is
jim carrey after all but the film's take
on the character is subpar
there's no doubt that inconsistent
writing on gotham led to a few rough
patches in terms of character work over
the years but the fox prequel series
deserves kudos for deepening and
enriching the backstories of several
batman villains and that was especially
true of corey michael smith's edward
nigma this version of enigma was
different from previous riddlers in that
the villain was presented as a fully
rounded three-dimensional character with
an engrossing storyline all his own
gotham introduced him as an eccentric
ostracized forensic scientist at the
gotham city police department as he
began to realize that his intelligence
gave him an upper hand over the people
who mistreated and belittled him we got
to see him slowly give in to his
narcissistic psychopathic impulses and
assume the persona of a full-fledged
villain you want to know why i could
never love someone like you oh i'm
warning you because you are a spoiled
child who throws a tantrum anytime he
doesn't get what he wants
smith was an absolute superstar in the
role allowing us to empathize with be
terrified of or absolutely loathe the
living daylights out of nigma many
batman fans would argue that it was the
best ever translation of the spirit of
the comics riddler to the screen
if corey michael smith's edward nigma
stands tall as arguably the most perfect
orthodox take on the riddler paul dano's
edward nashton is making a splash for
the exact opposite reason the savvy
retrofitting of the riddler into the
newest batman film is a terrifying
serial killer and maybe the most out
there live-action interpretation of the
character yet but he's so effective so
indelible that we wouldn't be surprised
if dana's performance ended up
influencing future riddlers for decades
to
[Music]
come what makes nashton such a brilliant
villain is that writers matt reeves and
peter craig were able to hone in on the
most essential psychological aspects of
the riddler the writers placed those
elements within a context that wholly
reshapes who the riddler is the core
theme of the character has always been
power its pursuit its exchange the way
it can shift at the drop of a hat on the
most basic level the riddler is a man
who renders his enemies helpless the
batman understands that disposition for
the perfect horror movie fodder it is
reeves film rings unspeakable dread out
of nashton's way of messing with batman
gotham city pd and his victims almost
like a cat playing with a mouse
the way the character is integrated into
real world social dynamics is similarly
pitch perfect his hordes of rabid social
media followers mirroring the sense of
bottomless despair that today is
extremist cult mentality prone internet
ecosystem tends to invite it's not the
riddler we're used to but it's the
riddler for our times
as the decades have brought about darker
deeper emotionally heftier screen
adaptations of the batman comics the
majority of the villains on the
light-hearted 60s batman series have
been surpassed by subsequent versions
that however is not the case with frank
gorshian's riddler the actor's take on
the character essentially define the
riddler as we know him from personality
to mannerisms to that unmistakable evil
flair
i am the prince of puzzlers the count of
conundrums the king of crime i hold
court here no one else
before the classic batman show the
riddler had been mostly relegated to
minor one-off appearances in the comics
it was the runaway success of the
character's tv appearances that inspired
dc comics to feature him more and more
prominently they eventually turned him
into a fixture of the batman rogues
gallery and the inevitable influence of
gorshin's performance is the way
audiences came to know him it wouldn't
be much of an exaggeration to say that
gorshin is the riddler the success of
gorshin's work earned him a prime time
emmy nod for outstanding performance by
an actor and a supporting role in a
comedy that led to subsequent
appearances in the 1966 film spin-off
and the 1979 tv special legends of the
superheroes
every riddler sense whether imitating it
deconstructing it or subverting it has
been a response to gorham's riddler on
some level check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos about the batman are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]